j'ai juste écrit une question c'est tout
c'est bien ce que je pense
ok donc les mois je veux dire attendez
moi ça me donne du simple lorsqu'on
prend ses rangs du cerveau ok donc du
cerveau alors vous mettez tout ce qui
est dit mais la vue de ses devoirs tout
ce qui influence qu on peut penser à toi
tu fais quoi la société dans laquelle on
est louise est de chez nous elle est
sans mal par moins raciste
enfin c'est un peu plus probable qu'on
soit un petit peu raciste aussi parce
que comment nous élève devons nous
élever comme comme eux y pense c'est lui
peut dire que notre style
ce qu'on pense salir notre style que
l'ong de nous m
il ya de la vie de tous les jours qui
viennent un poids de ce qu'on apprend ok
vous avez vu là c'est déjà commencer à
dire bah en fait voilà pourquoi on pense
à douce anne bien commencé à
déconstruire en fait il faut on va on va
tout le temps déconstruit les enfants
ses cinq buts
des fois on arrête on croit comprendre
ce que voulait dire beaucoup pour
reformer de ce que vous dites alors
qu'en fait c'est pas du tout et vous
vous dites oui parce que vous dites que
c'est peut-être mieux dit oh j'en sais
rien mais en fait c'est pas ça
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien ne pas avoir à faire des
trucs habituels de discipline genre vous
des places toussa toussa supplay
autorégulé vous
on va mettre là où pour aller beaucoup
moins tout ça tout ça mais on va
travailler ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc moi j'aimerais maintenant qu'on
aborde justement notre sujet sous le
sexisme en crise qu'on entende aux
parents ce qu'on voit à la télé que je
pense que j'avais plein de sources d
influence et est du coup voilà j'aimerai
globalement vous nous dire ce que vous
pensez du sexisme bas tout sexisme c'est
comme du racisme qui a essayé de veda
montrent que sinon on perd des fois
d'informer et écoutez bien tout ce qui
est dit n'est ce pas que l'on travaille
tu te prives en n'écoutant pas les
autres via la plupart des films connus
des suppôts si les gars qui font un
super héros ap aaron de roumains mais
que tous les regards
y'a rien l'illusion canadien c'est qu'il
n'y a plus de batman
les filles comme publicité tu vois
surtout dans les biberons rose elles ont
les vêtements roses leurs jouets même
n'est joué même si on leur donne des
voitures et boîtes roses aux filles pour
aimer double sur les boîtes
il avait du bleu est aussi possible au
dessus et là c'est pas ma double ou
d'autres leurs coffres rénovation les
garçons 16 heures après ok il est dit
bleu passeligne parce qu'ils pensent que
garçons bleus fille rose mais regardez
pour wii et des jouets à premier dg
bleus pour ya des joueurs aux presque si
ea mère à l enfant un garçon et un
enfant le garçon s'il est pour kadhafi
la main va lui acheter un vélo bleu
elle va le dire elle va se dire bah je
vais pas donner le vélo bleu à la fille
elle va racheter un vélo rose elle va le
demeurer près de caen fait c'est pour
vous
plus ils disent par exemple il ya une
fille qui aime le rose toutes les filles
aiment le rose bah oui parce que tout
l'hiver n'est pas par manque aujourd'hui
à des garçons bien les yeux toutes les
personnes et ils pensent tous la même
chose à ses 21 106 que doute qu'avec sa
phrase jamais comment expliques tu dis
en fait il pense qu'une personne
représente toutes les personnes c'est ça
on estime en dans les socialisation ça
va être le fond de sujets quant à agathe
a commencé à travailler sur les
stéréotypes sexistes avec des enfants un
plan de lutte gouvernemental contre ces
mêmes stéréotypes a suscité une
véritable révolte dans le pays mais
agathe ne s'est pas découragée
aujourd'hui ces ateliers sont parmi les
plus populaires de l'école de la cybèle
et heureusement car les spécialistes le
répète les graines qui permettent aux
discriminations et aux violences
sexistes de proliférer dans notre
société sont plantés dès le plus jeune
âge
depuis des générations et des
générations nous vraiment fermé leurs
portes et conques où est ce que tu sais
ce que tu veux faire plus tard dans la
nuit car ils crise qui régule crise si
tu étais un garçon qu'est ce que tu
aurais aimé faire comme métier
inspecteur inspecteurs de quoi publie
l'inspecteur de police un homme
et tu penses que tu veux pas être
inspectrice de police en temps utile non
pourquoi
c'est juste pas ça y est c'est pas tes
quoi richard ya des fans de glisse oui
mais c'est des secrétaires je vais tout
faux policiers que si vous aviez ted
expliquer ce que vous auriez fait comme
métier pourquoi était plutôt ratée de
puéricultrice par exemple garçon manqué
par exemple intéressant quand on se dit
c'est une fille elle est forte alors
qu'elle devait faire le ménage
elle a pas peur de la ventura leur cas
devrait avoir peur dès qu'elle voit le
petit animal prenons un exemple à darcy
port c'est par garçons en crise et juste
vicat pas peur d'eux du risque c'est une
fille tu as eu lé c'est un garçon manqué
elle a le droit de jouer avec des
garçons et pas forcément jouer avec
landry on va essayer de comprendre cette
expression faut pas qu'on se disperse en
fait on va essayer d'analyser cette
notion du garçon entier qu'est ce qu'il
ya derrière justement ça va venir avec
ce que tu l'aies dire on va écouter oui
parce qu'elle va s'arracher le bras les
grands
une garce marc et sophie manqué c'est
que il pense en fait de les recueillir
un caractère de filles qui ont vidé tout
le temps des bonnes écoles nous neuf
qu'on adore le rôle des robes tout le
temps à tous et un caractère de garçons
un effort en défense des gros mots non
non non non non je déconne et est écoles
système porter du rose du thème lire des
livres
pour finir notre part a dead set à venir
des romans d'amour ou balade tu assumes
quoi tu vas pas il faut dire à tes à
courdemanges dame maï tu vas le faire en
cachette et qui on a un fier de tes amis
qui les courses et monte à vie elle
finie
pour m voilà vous marchez absolue n'est
une révolution elle plaît qu'on peut
mais auront rien alors qu'elle a dit à
une révolution combattait menashe
absolue maintenant on est là parce que
tu as de beaux palais sexisme s'ils ont
un peu pareil dit a rapporté jana moins
désarmés
cette première les hommes et les femmes
en fait juste que ton enfant jusqu'à sa
mort il y presque si les femmes et on
s'est révoltés va les gars vont prendre
très mal et en fait ça va devenir comme
une guerre entre les hommes et les
femmes est admissible ou c'est parce
qu'on veut c'est juste qu'ils l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes c'est à
dire qu'est ce que tu plonges les
garçons quand on est tranquille suis
comme des chiens des figures comme par
exemple leur courant passe et qui font
que de cris bien sûr si vous les embêter
moi non pas une prière
je suis pas fier
[Applaudissements]
les variables de cet ingrédient mention
[Musique]
je sais que c'est un peu pour garder la
face des fois un peu enfermé par vos
égos tout ça juste je faisais déjà on a
déjà parlé de ça j'ai déjà fait des
discours à tous individuellement c'est
bon libérez-vous pas besoin de tout
temps répondre juste pour être hors jeu
devant les autres vous laissez pas
enfermer par le regard des autres genres
juste on vous demande une consigne il a
voulu respecter peu importe que pour ses
autres hockey pendant que notre édition
d'hier un petit peu ok donc oublier soir
de connexion c'est juste en droit est ce
que si votre fils vous dit voilà je vais
acheter des barbies même plus loin un
genre je vais acheter du maquillage
oui bah oui parce que si je n'avais pas
vraiment un plaisir je suis pas tous en
même temps dire et je n'ai pas eu
d'enfance et le nouvel an je suis
d'accord si l'art du maquillage
coquilles et le bonheur qui veut on est
battu et je suis très heureux qu'on
arrive dans les salles heureux par
exemple tu veux mettre du maquillage ou
encore les barbus ça me dérange pas mais
franchement un enfant par exemple qui
peut s'habiller à juba en robe et tout
ça on va dire que c'est séraphine et
aures non c'est râpé
la première fille qui arrive en proto à
mon avis les gens ils avoir le même avis
que toi la matinée quand tu vois un
garçon qui veut et qui par exemple est
dit que toi tu avais dit non mais moi
façon mon fils ça n'arrivera pas sur
demande sans vraiment s est dit alors
aisé de réfléchir pour qu'est ce qui te
fait faire des trucs de filles et toi
côté il ya la fille s'appelle tu en as
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu penses que ton fils demandera jamais
ça tu seras ça n'arrive à cause d
exprimer
vas-y 2 essaye de le déconstruire ce qui
se passe dans ta tête
d'où ça vient ça là y'a rien qui devient
le fait que tu sais pas d'où ça vient en
fait le premier
la première chose que je vais le faire
c'est pas c'est pas une vie tranquille
comme moi j'ai pu lui donner un ballon
de foot je peux le dire
vas-y tire dans le ballon tourner le
ballon moi je moi je vais dire va zy va
avec qui tu veux mais enfin oui je vais
lui dire voir qui tu veux mais pas avec
des dijonnais avec jean louis s'est
croisé jean basique
voilà
[Musique]
oh
pour l'instant installez-vous elle a
besoin tableau ci dessus
on savait que voilà si on aborde les
sujets du sexisme c'est pour participer
à un concours par une production de
visuels donc on l'a happé un peu de
sensibilisation
on en fait aussi le mardi on pourra
aller plus loin on peut enfin prendre
très longtemps mais on a quand même un
tas ligne à respecter donc l'idée ce
serait de faire en gros une sorte de
chaperon rouge qu'on suit la caméra suit
donc on la voit de dos avancé elle ouvre
la porte du petit parc et à tourner la
tête et avoir trois petits cochons donc
juste avec les masses qui sont là
inoffensifs en train de jouer sur les
jeux ea on commence à avoir une ambiance
plutôt inquiétante sombrer tout ça donc
simplement avancer seul
et là en fait il ya un garçon habillé en
en sweat à capuche qui arrive qu'ils
disent genre c'est que c'est un jeu pour
une fille des premiers soutiennent et là
on part sur autre chose
on part sur les princesses et les
princesses qui viennent à la rescousse
de leurs potes qui en galets d'accord
donc ce n'est pas la princesse qui est
passive qui attend entre prince charmant
c'est la princesse qui va aider sa
copine il est à solidarité de fait mine
qui ont 30 s'installer actuellement
l'idée de la belle au bois dormant qui
devrait annoncer de presse qu'il arriva
et balla non le prince limited arrive et
elle le bazar j'ai pas le temps à
invalider sa faute
plusieurs situations comme ça il ya des
princesses qui réagissent et la dapo on
voit la fille avec une arme et filles et
qui parle de la qualité qui 10000 thème
tête c'est pas que maintenant on essaie
de plus laisser faire enfin j'avais déjà
fait un texte que j'avais plus ou moins
écrit mais là je me fais un peu à la
rage on essaie de plus laisser faire on
va être solidaire non non on a décidé de
parler de plus values pu rester dans le
silence je sais pas quoi il ya donc une
autre française qui dit on pas et là on
va être un petit cochon qui rebondit sur
un mode moins aussi sont des garçons eux
aussi subissent le mal parce que le loup
pareil mais mange on boit il ya que
quelques prédateurs pour une ensemble
deux garçons filles qui sont tranquilles
qui peuvent cohabiter où il n'y a pas de
problème on est sur l'actualité vraiment
défi solidaire que maintenant il ya un
attroupement qui fait que voilà ça va
plus être possible ce qui se passait
avant alors j'ai pas du tout été clair
je prends ce séminaire quoi mais là on
verra
avec débarrasser la vaisselle avec un
élevage et le mari une liste rouge
aurait été plus un talent et un moment
et lui balance
ils ont charmé les mains sur la tête et
du presque tout trempé elle peut aussi
vous dernières seront au lieu que si
seul garçon qui donne une veuve et la
fille s'il est coupable ce serait la
fille qui garderait pas face à changé
mais elle n'offre aux paysages chinois
mais là parce que le but le but c'est
d'avoir un message positif quand même on
va reprendre juste les bases de compte
mais on va pas faire des situations
inversé ou le pot mais qui se fait taper
par samba faut comprendre en fait il ya
une double peine voire même plus qu'une
grève est liée en fait il ya le talent
immense élan vers les filles mais aussi
envers les garçons
vas-y moussa rapidement non je dois
tourner le truc c'est quand même les
deux font plein de bêtises
l'idée c'est que les deux soient
tranquilles cool ça se passe bien ce que
si tout le monde et amène à moussa notre
monde je pense qu'il va devenir
ça va être un beau bazar et qu'on aime
je viens viens aussi même quand vous
fait mal parce que finalement ce que les
filles vous reproche en général ou
garçons c'est d'être un peu brutaux
violent et toi qu'est ce que tu
reproches aux filles aussi sont
violentes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les
aïe fois qu'il y ait effectivement toute
la planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est souhaitable
[Musique]
si plus rien vous avez vu il ya quatre
pôles de tournage ici vous doutez bien
se fait la belle au bois dormant
ici c'est blanche-neige et son bras
c'est serra ici c'est les 3 autres et là
bas ce sera sourire content poteau ni si
vous êtes tous par là ok et faux pas de
pollution sonore dont pages aux biches
ah ben moi delnard homme et je suis
dégouté je voulais faire externe alors
on va commencer par ouï fm horizontale
semble haute et le micro s'appuie là et
moi aussi je vais filmer en même temps
alors légaux les grands derrière les
petits devant logis tin tuc roumanie au
palms quais de seine en blanche neige et
c'est là où tu te rends compte exact que
j'ai dû faire la vaisselle et la soupe à
cet adulte on savait même pas s'occuper
d'eux quand je tente où quelques
ondulations les pauvres ont dû supprimer
ces deux bulles
vous rigolez engage tous ces nouveaux
métiers 3 l'idée la cptaq optimisé mais
où était vous avez droit de
jamais failli vous aurez un couple et
leur jeu de remplaçants sortir des spas
james et vous ça c'est pas mon boss n'a
pas écrit
l effort on a commencé devient on a fait
une sas elle avait un rôle accélère la
gauche disent ils ont senti les gars
ceux qui font du bruit chaque aidant
c'est pareil on n'a pas le temps
[Musique]
on
tant pis si rigolo mais enfin c est le
tout pour les on sait le faire ensemble
moi j'ai pas envie tous portés surtout
ne suis pas capable de le faire j'ai
besoin de vous et vous avez besoin de
moi donc phone est interdépendant mon
plat vous mettiez du vôtre
[Musique]
à ce jour ce basculement de romans dans
la boîte et celle de choc
[Musique]
il à malicounda ça marche
quel point de nice et cif
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as une idée de ce que tu
veux faire plus tard comme métier
ingénieur génie roncquois août où tu
m'as dit que tu voulais être quoi dans
la vie
vers quel métier d'infirmière bon alors
cuir à ton travail mais invente un
travail qu'est ce que tu feras oui je
peux la haye et après je vais voler oui
je m'habillais du pur entends ton
travail qu'est ce que tu feras celle des
copains
oui on voit la maïté fille je crois
manger et après la trêve le dîner
témoigne c'est bien celui là est ce que
vous pensez quand un garçon vous avez
aussi des contraintes qu'on vous impose
ce parce que vous êtes garçons et du
compte ils réduisent la liberté non si
ce nom vous est pas que les garçons
aussi ils ont des contraintes qui les
empêchent d'être vraiment libre et
d'être vraiment ce qu'ils veulent être
convié de face à une décision quand vous
les verrez les choses et un respect ça
vous est déjà arrivé deux voilà donc ne
pas oser de soutien limitées de dire non
pour moi ou et est-ce que vous pensez
que les garçons ça leur arrive c'est ce
qu'ont pensé que les garçons sont
limitées aussi ils sont même plus
limitée que les filles pourquoi je si
une fois un truc qui a l'air d'une fille
eh ben ils ont peur de se faire juger
par les autres mais vivent alors qu'une
mais franchement et puis aussi ainsi ici
de toute heure je suis pelletan mes
mains mais si tu fais honte à quelqu'un
qui
tu as une fille tu es une fille qui veut
faire quelque chose du foot ou quoi que
ce soit eh ben on va la refuser
plusieurs choix recettes dépendent ici
parce que tu te poses pas léger avec les
garçons voilà le faisais même toit
jantes on te considère comme la relation
quelle que soit voilà c'est
contrebalancé des réponses politiques
sur nous parce que dit on va tous des
réseaux enterrés dans chaque classe ya
toujours une fille qu'il me voie at il
enfin se démarquer après mais tout est
ce que tu dis c'est hyper sexy ce temps
rien ne dit que c'est cette guerre sans
dentelles
mais j'ai pas dicter du garçon qui n'ont
myrage je dis que je veux aller jouer au
foot parce que j'ai peur que les garçons
se moque de moi et on conçoit que toi il
métro golwyn mauresmo quesnel après
chacun sait peu reçu malgré toi tu sais
que tu vas te mettre plus de choses que
moi alors que moi je vais me permets de
moindre chose que toi tu te permets oui
ça dépend en pettis participants faire
plus qu'elle tu dis qu'il ya plus de moi
des berthier progression on passe pas
ainsi qu'il va faire des choses
considérées comme les meneurs et batman
vu la fille qui veut faire du foot même
si elle peut subir quelques rejette les
autres filles vont pas se moquer d'elle
non c'est dire quoi c'est dire que
l'univers masculin il est quand même
valorisé même par le parlement considère
pas trop le fait que les garçons sont
aussi que j'aime parler sexisme on pense
plutôt aux filles mais en vrai il faut
prendre en compte que les garçons aussi
ils sont vraiment toucher vraiment
beaucoup par ça et peut-être plus
maintenant faut pas déconner non mais
attends tu montes parler foot qui se
passe là en ce moment non mais les
seules elles donnent qui se cache depuis
[Musique]
moi je dis que les femmes et les gars
les femmes et les hommes subissent
autant de sexisme et l'appréhension de
formes différentes dire que la femme on
va plutôt voilà la oui je sais je sais
mais je suis pas d'un naturel suite
pendant toute sa vie le même genre on
lui dit de pas jouer au football pendant
une seconde il s'en faudra je sais marla
c'est qu'ils en subissent à parts égales
mais il ya des femmes subissent des
choses beaucoup plus graves et les
hommes
alors moi je suis là tu justement je
vais lire une phrase qui vous comprenez
pas y'a pas de soucis donc les systèmes
de croyances limitantes comme les
stéréotypes contribué à dessiner des
places et capacités ou des attitudes aux
hommes et aux femmes au détriment de
leurs propres réalisations perçoit lui
ce que vous comprenez
[Musique]
action vas-y clément ravir health et
avance en même temps j'ai c'est
dangereux pour une fille les trous tout
seul coupez tu l'aurais rendait en
sourire alors imagine vraiment là tu
dois tu dois faire peur ou tu as genre
pour ça quand tu veux pas du fait des
coups de pression comme ça je sais que
ça t'arrive presque t'énerver sinon
parce que tu es énervé et vaty long
terme était énervé rapprocher voire un
tout petit peu jean limite même dans ta
classe non verbale il faut que tu sois
un peu présent donc tu es un peu en
avant que tu vois genre voilà et toi tu
es toi tu en maths et en vente est un
peu en mode un peu défensif rod culture
ont alors il sans sourire au caire ont
fait sa sortie
ouais tu peux avancer en parlant et toi
tu recules en deux temps mais sans
sourire vraiment manu soit ce poste fixe
aussi tenir prospective et agressé ce
truc qui me critiquent jusqu'à chez papa
pourra-t-il je pense à manuel ponce
ajustements tout ce qui te rend ou para
post agression sexuelle tu me parle tout
le temps toi qui m'en parlent tout le
temps tu crois que tu connais même mieux
que moi ta à fond dans plus que moi donc
maintenant voilà france à ça près c'est
que ces deux jeux pour une fille du
premier tout seul coupé fait comme quand
on est énervé imagine là tu t'es
disputer et pour cela toutes les fois où
était énervé par sa quantité en r&d
clément et que mais on s'en fiche reste
brise pas pour saab à la province
constitue veux tu fais ce que tu veux
mais tu crois
voilà c'est ça que je veux ok ça tourne
action
je crois ou p il a 18 c'est parfait on
rend dans le times y va essayer de
monter là
ok on va par deux s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
maintenant qu'on a un parent c est que
vous avez pu avoir incarné un peu la
situation et ça j'allais voir si ça a
changé votre définition du sexisme qui
pourrait me dire l'âme annoncent qu'ils
pensent du sexisme ou ce que david a
sélectionné pour l'oscar pas on se rend
compte en fait que tout le monde est
touché par le sexisme est aussi bon en
se déguisant en en parlant il peut
éviter quand on sera grand et sexiste
jamais cette façon parce que tu pourras
pour déguisement en quoi ce débat
vieillissement va par exemple
non mais qu'on voudrait se faire en
scène mettre en scène des
des trucs que contre le sexisme moi je
me suis de kant watan au début tu sais
on attend plusieurs proches c'est
tellement il dit qui a fait beaucoup
d'armes et toi tu as fait beaucoup de
morts est-ce que vous souvenez conseil
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire ou es ce
que vous avez constaté remarqué c'est
pathétique autre tour mais c'est hyper
intéressant ce qui s'est passé à da je
n'aime pas c'est clair quand il avait
bouclé au dos reis vous souvenez ce qui
s'est passé il se faisait bates oui à
l'essai et du feu est doux et basse et
on l'a dit je veux une fille donc un
vrai de vrai les aigus mais je ne sais
pas comment comment y me tenais je suis
pas en fait je sais pas comment est une
fille voilà cela dépeint dit qu'on n'est
pas dans la peau d'une fille
on peut pas vraiment savoir et ça s'est
fait à présent sa part du jeu des leurs
et au repas gras ne fallait plutôt
fringant je l'écouterai d'accord sur une
façade à ceux comme c'est une fille amy
tu es un garçon à la pas vraiment est
pareil que le garçon ne s'est pas
limitée parfaitement dont on n'a pas
tous la même nature donc on sait pas
vraiment comment limiter donc
imaginons prenons un garçon qui est un
peu féminin
je dis n'importe quoi ahmed par exemple
c'est pas un garçon qui aime jouer au
foot et tout ça donc on sait pas trop
comment l'éviter
j'ai laissé mes gars là répond mais en
fait tu es sûr que tu dis on va prendre
pied à un garçon qui a plutôt un
caractère féminin
bah en fait y'a pas de caractère féminin
georges paillas pas commis c'est la même
chose mais voilà c'est pas du tout les
mêmes par exemple tu prends manuela et
non pas les mêmes choses ce qu'a dit ada
c'est hyper important
elle a 10 par rapport à ton goût tu dis
oui mais moi je suis fils comme à mtn
film il ya tellement une variété même
pour une fille meeting filles c'est
compliqué il faut rentrer dans un
système de sens différent du sien
une fille n'est pas universelle comme un
garçon n'est pas universelle c'est ça la
scène après matt hic c'est que on dans
le sexisme on attend c'est très binaire
très dichotomie qui a d'un côté l'autre
côté les filles les garçons univers
fineberg garçons alors qu'en fait c'est
des prismes via un prisme énorme avec
des polarités mais la bure des gens sont
dans ce prisme sont pas dans je suis
garé de la turdine il ya les caricatures
mais finalement pas la majorité regarder
s'il ya des caricatures de filles parce
que dirais tu retires le garçon bat pas
vraiment mais si on est admiratif de a
par exemple mais bien le foot mais ça
paye le foot c'est pas forcément les
garçons jeu sans merci dit ça on dit
c'est quoi la maladie s'est rendu ce
texte et son ce même plus pragmatique
tout
[Musique]
oh
alors l'exercice est simple on va faire
vous allez faire un portrait robot
donc voilà il vraiment le garçu l'âme
idéal quoi d'accord la replantation de
l'homme idéal donc vous mettez physique
et personnalités qui veut écrire ai dit
ok donc tu fais de toi tu fais le tour
de table par exemple on voit tout le
monde s'est tu joues pour toi c'est quoi
le mec idéal méchant donc d'abord pas
fait les deux physique personnalités
comme vous voulez c'est pas moi des
trucs bien zinc qui veut mettre un
cueilleur chantier n'ont pas imaginé
voilà vos modèles orientation ce que
vous aimez donc accueilli un gentil trop
intensif accord avec antidote n'ont
jamais lâché par certains qui veut en
brut six aventuriers les ans près ce que
vous aimeriez ressembler à axione geo
pourquoi rien ne vient pas plaire aux
filles ont tous les muscles sur les
actions
comment vous allez faire un portrait
robot 2 ce qui est pour vous la famille
des attentats tous et toujours de bonne
humeur
tu veux vraiment dire un sale caractère
de te dire du caractère divin grosse car
la salle carette bien s'ils s'affirment
c'est un gros caractère mais pas
forcément non ça se remet ça veut pas
dire avoir un groupe non effectivement
ne pas te travestir tout va être
incorporé au groupe c au site affirmé
peut-être se dire bah non je vais pas
changer ce que je suis pour être
acceptée je m'affirme en tant que
personne moi je suis comme ça je vais
pas changer pour eux ça peut être ça
aussi la formation s'est pas s'imposer
c'est pas la force c'est pas peut-être
que si vrai qu'on travaille sur les
termes vous avez pris 0,30 à sion aussi
des choses savent ça mais c'est pas
forcément ce qu'on évite que tu prends
ce modèle mais tu veux m'expliquer ce
que c'est pour toi l'affirmation ça toi
c'est pas pour te mettre en branle pas
pour mettre en difficulté valeo la cie
comprend aussi avec c'est parce qu'on
pourrait aller plus loin et si vous
préférez être des garçons ou auriez
préféré de défis mais bien ressembler
actionne aujourd'hui vous avez un choix
à faire
c'est ça vous choisiriez oui c'est à
dire être un homme d'action avant vous
dit votre idéal fit donc à la fois
physique et personnalités et après
comment vous allez présenter dans la
société avait d'abord votre idéal à vous
physique oui mais avec une ficelle
quelque chose si justin gymnastes enfin
sportif quoi ok je tendis les gentils
[Musique]
pied que tipi et alors ce qui est légal
mais kuyt invasif
c'est vraiment les garçons ça suffit les
lire sur les pieds là continuez les
caractéristiques préféré qu'elle soit
moche vous préférez c'est moi qui vais
lâcher est ce que vous préférez laisser
vous voulez il sombre idiote qui est pas
drôle et qui est embêtante et ses
collègues décrivent et des reprises à
cette roma chose que vous avez et je
pense que vous avez quand même des
critères à tous
vous aimez pas lui fit drôle vous qui
travaillez sicile et pour les âges pour
le ménage et villages les arts déco ou
ravaille et puis les fameuses
voyez pour des courses on suit vous
pouvez ça bien sûr et raisonnable
elle est rapidement calculez votre idéal
dire son physique c'est parti vas-y m'a
dit musclé mais serait quoi d'autre
l'intelligent une personnalité
intelligente drôle drôlement oui c'est
possible sensible on attend déjà dopage
une hôtesse tu passes à la face pour que
les beats je fais franchement je ne vois
vraiment pas ce que hockey intelligent
sensible attentionné rôle social que
cette écriture web youtube s'inquiète
pas notre hockey physique
quoi d'autre en physique beau et musclé
normes alors vous voulez qu'ils soient
petits m'amuserais pas que ce petit plus
il vaut mieux des bosons que dans des
lieux avant je me couper ma technique ok
contiennent pas de classe à temps
[Rires]
[Musique]
personnalité ce sportif jean qui
attentionné intelligent qui aiment
bouger paresseuse drôle cuisinière qui
sort les poubelles et pas nerveuse moi
j'en ai coupés alors euh c'est quoi se
ressaisir et moyenne taille moyenne
grande fatigue petite fille et 33 métis
je t'avoue lancé je suis lancé je plains
pas coureur de jupons genre ont gâché
toutes les filles marie rien n'y fait on
sent trop maniaque et pas vous donner
maniaque c'est un peu plus excessifs oui
[Musique]
non voilà c'est parce que par un
perfectionniste ça fait du com qualité
comme un défaut il ya deux versions
petit payeurs sont négatifs s'appelle
lionel roux et ça peut être un peu
excessif aussi ça peut paraître rigide
un peu donc à voir
voilà comment vous l'interprétez et
comme on faisait avec manuel tadros voir
ce que vous mettez des rats les mots
comme une histoire de s'affirmer sait
jamais c'est pas forcément dans la
violence être assertif c'est affirmer
son avis certains frapper mais tu es
forcément par la force en imposant ou
pas forcément savons parlant fort
ils te prennent comme ça aussi en criant
tu peux les répondre lors non vivres à
ces seules intelligence et se tailladant
écrite ce tu as bien s'amuser mais du
côté faussement imagine quelqu'un qui
est agressif avec toi mais de là
imaginer avec de l'humour très puissante
eu à l'entrée un truc quelque chose de
très très faim tu lui tu lui remballe sa
réplique de façon très drôles sont
énervés non justement non ça se trouve
tu peux l'affiché devant tout le monde
et d'un style tu peux tu énervé quand
même non bah le mieux en fait ce n'est
qu'il a ça veut dire aussi que tu te
laisses atteindre ça veut dire que
l'huile est content il est ce qu'il veut
tu es sûr que 8e tu leur mets ton le cri
encore si je vais à le remettre à sa
place sans consommer trop d'énergie tu
te fais du mal à ton corps que
physiologiquement six autres corps dans
les abonnements c'est pas bon donc en
fait une des ses yeux si vous le dit la
rumeur et je suis là non celle x et
installe à des tiers superman heures
vive la différence entre toi et ados
typiquement vous êtes de deux films
affirmé d'accord soit plus justement en
mode frontale combat et elle par une
réplique et diva dire brut pendant que
c'est christophe asselin ruminants à
nyala et adobe et donc il sait pas ce
qu'il y ait ou du coup voilà elle valait
à guichet ouvert et qui sait pas ce
qu'il dit je laisse mes il dit un truc
plus graves
ok je peux crier assez bon mais je dis
pas que tu peut vous paraître bien sûr
talent dans tous les cas sa loi de
crétins sa droite se défendre avec tes
armes
voilà après bien sûr que c'est bien moi
je suis plus pour le respect et voilà
pour le pas de ne pas laisser libre
cours à des émotions négatives titre on
aussi vont aller garçons et s'énerve et
ça ne vient pas
c'est super que c'est bien cela faisait
de la faiblesse en fait c'est une
vulnérabilité simple à gérer les
émotions si chris classe et quand on te
faire des deux os à des choses que tu as
maîtrise de son contrôle c'est pas ce
pas noble enfants mais s'il ya les deux
qui explique forcément au bout d'un
moment le temps mais ça sert à quoi sa
femme aimante nivellement vers le bas
après on jette toi à travers la pièce
oui mais est-ce que c'est ça l'idéal est
ce que c'est ça vous admirez et bah faut
chercher d'autres proposent que c'est la
chercher avec méthode on va écouter adam
non je dis pas ça je dis pas sa manière
non mignon si par exemple tu vois
rigoler c'est ainsi que le maintien car
imagine un mec qui te recherche regard
dans la rue un mec tu y vas tu vas le
chercher soit tu fais ce genre
musculaire soit tu l'ignorent
complètement il est tout seul me prends
un gros vent et ça y est votre méthode
peut-être jean sera important et que tu
choisi l'autre méthode qui te met qui se
complaît pas forcément mais pourquoi sa
série tous les garçons tu fais ça ils te
font ça par tous on regarde ahmed situe
le circuit va pas non plus la joie ahmed
je pense que d'autres mais même sans
être agressif parce que tu peux ne
portait pas de gilet en maille dis pas
qu'il ya une bonne nouvelle technique
j'ai juste que ça peut être intéressant
d'essayer d'autres méthodes et que je
suis sûr que d'autres méthodes sont
bonnes ça j'en suis certaine mais
attendez là mais là il a violé l appel -
non mais c'est pas ça les regarde pas ça
l'année les atomes et fmi- s'avancer à
te faire agresser
elle féministe lui dire qu'elle sait des
contextes n'ont pas saisi tout avoue ta
pensée est menacé c'est ouf parce que tu
es vachement fort je me tue mais rien
n'ya pas de mal t'as pas je dis pas que
tu as tort manu là on avance moi c'est
pareil des fois ça fait bizarre dans le
ventre parce que les poussins nos
retranchements et c'est ça qui est bien
baba où vous inquiète pas ou prendre ton
temps tu vendes et coutadeur n'attend
que tu te ressaisisse mais y'a pas de
mal mais ça et que je vois que cette
fois c'est viscéral et moi aussi ce jeu
des fois il ya des choses qui matin et
moi je pense qu'on a des sensibilités
plus de castres avec d'autres mais c'est
intéressant c'est bien
l'idée c'est que je vais faire un
entraînement - pour les filles qui se
situera le à l'extérieur dit
d'entraînement de foot et vous les
garçons vous allez faire quelque chose
qui est très novateur je vais être les
pionniers de quelque chose l'idée si
vous fassiez les pom pom boy de tapis
par open de tapie homme dangereux deux
tapis là bas dans la longueur et de la
malbaie l'aller 4 vous travaillez cette
partie là et les caves où travaillent
sur cette partie d'accord l'idée l'idée
au mieux elles rigolent mais font la
même chose
l'idée l'idée terminé avec la ligier
c'est que vous là les quatre vous
fassiez quelque chose plutôt en ligne
parce que là le match qui va être ça va
être sur un terrain il est ses coûts
face et votre rigueur votre gant c'est
ok
[Musique]
donc ouais je sais rien
c'est génial
[Musique]
votre entraîneur elle était superbe ans
je suis parisien en bus les différents
trucs et une ruine roulades et après
vous reprenez tous ensemble mais après
la ce qu'ils auront plus c'est une
étoile à y mettre de la vois pas ce que
vous pas vu que vous êtes supporter et
du coup va falloir encourage être
[Musique]
ok elle pourrait me l'a faire prendre
franchement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas accroché parce que les gars
vous ai pas touché la balle en compte
pas cool pas cela allait compte pas
souri
[Applaudissements]
savez vous avez participé à un concours
quand même la vidéo qu'on a fait c'était
pour le concours et donc j'ai les
résultats définitifs
jésus sachez que compte quand on fait
une activité sportive et je vous dis
souvent l'importance est pas de gagner
pour gagner d'études dans la performance
ces salles mais au prix vous avez
partagé
bon tu connais 4e et 3e
les deuxièmes je veux dire le résultat
dans l'oreille tu as bien alors allez
beaucoup mouillé tallec sur tu aimes
regardez moi ou la menthe s'attend bien
mais je vis est très discrète
[Applaudissements]
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est normal que vous soyez contents
tant mieux serait ce serait bizarre oui
c'est vrai vu qu'il va voir les
cérémonies et que vous êtes premiers ça
vous engage à ne pas être là bas c'est
bon plat au revoir du coup hier la
cérémonie
vous serez au premier rang vous allez
passer devant il ya 200 places
c'est comme un grand cinéma et le but
c'est de s'exprimer devant les gens de
raconter un peu ce que vous avez vécu
ressenti un peu comme si vous avez payé
que tu avais fait en écrit et a fort à
faire en normal ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir réfléchir à des petits discours
donc là maintenant vous positionnez où
vous voulez je vous donne le matériel ou
noranda français que les hommes seront
supérieures en france mais c'est pas mal
d'imagés bien très bas semblent parfois
oui tu peux dire tu dois faire un prix
correct de la réitération
pourquoi parce que nous sommes pas nous
devons aussi dire ça pourquoi parce que
nous sommes pas traduit dans ce cas ton
discours et faire des cagoules cette
poésie bonsoir mesdames et mazel et
messieurs nous sommes tous très heureux
d'avoir eu le premier prix
j'ai été très heureux de participer à ce
concours contre les sexismes je vais
vous expliquer ce que j'ai retenu de
cette production
j'ai appris beaucoup sur le sexisme
c'est quelque chose de trésorerie
également j'ai appris sur le cinéma en
faisant ce projet géant veut que le
sexisme cesse d'exister grâce à ce
projet on a changé nos façons de penser
et de parler ça nous a permis de nous
rapprocher et de partager des choses
incroyables
bonsoir je vais vous parler du sac civ
si nous regardons le cas dans les
détails nous constatons que c'est
ignorer de penser que les hommes sont
supérieurs aux femmes
pourquoi quand une femme porte une jupe
elle a peur pourquoi pantin un voeu à
l'homme que de la danse il a peur des
moqueries
regardons le cas site une femme porte
une jupe elle a peur d'être agressé
sexuellement au subi un terreau marquis
ne sont pas agréables du genre tu es bon
au lit
vous trouvez vous ça normal dépenses
penser le et vous et vous verrez à bord
dont les âmes où les enfants garçons
vous verrez que la majorité des garçons
même s'il veut faire de la danse
classique ne supporterait pas le fait
d'être moqué c'est pour ça que nous
faisons ce projet et nous nous battons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les séismes ça commence quand ça
commence très tôt quand on est très
jeune donc du coup en effet c'est très
important de comprendre ce que c'est que
le sexisme d'être plus jeune âge
pour empêcher qu'un jour il en soit on
en arrive aux violences
[Musique]
c'est un jeu pour une fille de premier
ticket au moins le sexy mon chien peu
mais bon grain saragosse et n'a appris
beaucoup
donc en fait on l'a fait ce film pour
changer les mentalités pour qu'un jour
il y ait les égalités hommes/femmes et
j'espère que pour nous est que pour le
futur c'est mon changera bientôt
merci à limoges on aime bien le faire
quelque chose de ses mains
[Musique]
mais sa radio mais jouer sans et par
mois
d'affaires offertes
frais par conjointe carole tu
préfèrerais des objets ah oui j'aime et
je vais vous dire mon idée est vraiment
que au 20e siècle la roue visent souvent
par procuration la télévision vous offre
une image tout fait le jouet est déjà
donné il a déjà sa forme
on y ajoute très peu et moi je désire
donner aux enfants la liberté d'être de
merde
faux
[Musique]
je vois que j'avais pensé à jouer mixant
psg
[Musique]
rêvez pas sa ligne à la patinoire
alors faire un mini bilan bush menti
des coûts
[Musique]
et étrangers rendent plus
g
[Musique]
vous qui s'est éclatée l'an